boxing fans can start looking forward to
the biggest ever fight between two
British boxers a deal has been struck
for Anthony Joshua to fight Tyson Fury
for the undisputed heavyweight
championship of the world
Joshua's promoter Eddie Hearn tell Sky
News that contracts have not been signed
but both sides have agreed to the
financial terms the biggest fight in
British boxing history has just been
agreed to fight deal Tyson Fury vs
company Joshua next year please excited
let's speak to our sports correspondent
Martha Kanter who's also excited I
suppose and I mean a lot of boxing bouts
are over hype not this one no this is
very big indeed and as you mentioned
it's a fight that many boxing fans have
been waiting several years to hear that
is eventually all the cards now and when
it does happen it will be billed as the
biggest fight in British boxing history
there's no doubt about that and that is
understandable because Anthony Joshua is
a megastar of the sport he's at the very
top of his game he holds three of those
world heavyweight title belts while
Tyson Fiore holds the other one so this
is the chance in its simplest terms to
see who is the very best heavyweight
fighter in the world but so far they've
never met in the ring but that is about
to change the boxing promoter may be
home telling Sky Sports earlier on and
the deal had that a deal had been
reached and I think we can hear a little
bit of what he had to say it's the
biggest fight ever
in British boxing is two British
heavyweight world champions fighting for
the undisputed heavyweight world
championship so it doesn't get any
bigger and there will never be a bigger
fight I don't think probably in our
generation to be quite honest with you
and you've got two guys you know both
very different both fight differently
both experienced different things in
their career I've come back from
adversity at one stage or the other and
I just think it's got everything
well Martha everyone's appetites been
well and truly wetted but so we want to
know when and where well it's a to fight
deal that's been struck and we think the
first time that they'll fight will be in
the summer of 2021 depending of course
on what happens with the coronavirus and
if it's able to be staged with fans
which will of course be the overwhelming
wish of the fight promoters the big
question is where will this fight be
held my understanding is that promoters
from Saudi Arabia and we're over in
London just before the coronavirus shut
down speaking to Anthony Joshua's team
and expressing their wish that they
would host this fight they've clearly be
a controversial host on human rights
grounds and that they did host Anthony
Joshua's previous most recent fight
against the American Mexican andy ruiz
and you'd also think that wembley would
be in the frame perhaps cardiff or maybe
even las vegas which is of course host
of many of the biggest fights in boxing
history both men do have to fight before
that and not in significantly for Tyson
Fury he faces the man known as the
bronze bomber born
Deonte wild who's an incredibly
dangerous prospect as Tyson Fury was
saying rather breathlessly earlier this
fight against Anthony Joshua is the big
one it's the one boxing fans have all
been waiting for